los congresistas demócratas buscan
activar el proceso para que donald trump
se convierta en el único presidente en
la historia del país en ser sometido a
dos juicios políticos más de 180
miembros de la bancada opositora del
congreso que patrocinaron un artículo de
acusación por incitación a la
insurrección que será presentado el
lunes según lo confirmado por el
representante por california
permítame simplemente decir esto donald
trump debe ser removido de su cargo
inmediatamente
amiri ley that's why the house es por
eso que la cámara está buscando todos
los medios disponibles a nuestra
disposición para lograr el objetivo de
hacer responsable presidente de eeuu
trump rechazado por un número creciente
de funcionarios republicanos y
silenciado por twitter ahora amenaza con
crear una plataforma digital paralela
mientras tanto continúa la ola de
arrestos contra los servidores radicales
del mandatario que atacaron la sede
legislativa y que se vitorearon
vandalizando las instalaciones del
capitolio ya son más de 80 detenidos
según
alcalde de nueva york los actos
violentos de sedición fueron incitados
por el presidente republicano
misma gracias a estos miembros del
congreso que impugnarán a donald trump
porque los necesitamos los necesitamos
para proteger a eeuu y la democracia
americana el tema corts y sin embargo
las posibilidades de que las medidas
para remover a trump del cargo prosperen
son pocas el vice presidente mike pence
no planea invocar la enmienda 25 según
fuentes de la casa blanca y cualquier
impugnación en la cámara de los
representantes provocaría un juicio en
el senado controlado por los
republicanos que está previsto que entre
en receso hasta el 19 de enero y ya ha
absuelto a trump antes